bonsoir tout le monde c'est un grand
honneur d'être parmi vous je suis
mariana dominguez penya els 20 comédiens
et cinéastes comme vous avez remarqué
jean petit tacle en georgie mexicaine
même si j'ai pas de chapeau ni des
points job je vous assure je m'excuse
j'ai partie de mon pays il ya six ans je
suis arrivé en france en compagnie de ma
mère et de mon fils je me sois sûr
commencer desservant n'est pas chose
simple mais pour me donner du courage je
me disais je vais y arriver
c'est difficile mais c'est possible avec
cette énergie
je me suis dit il faut que je fasse
quelque chose pour m'en sortir
donc je me suis mis à vendre des légumes
à côté de l'autoroute
parfois je fais c'est les ménages ces
gens et grâce à la solidarité des gens
qu'ils m'entendent maman je suis
aujourd'hui je suis là pour vous
présenter deux projets qui me tient à
coeur et qui sont 1 diffusé par
l'association que mon collègue et moi
nommons association sirène dans les
premières projet c'est un film de long
métrage
qu'est-ce qu'ils intitulent l'étrange
anatomy des rêves c'est un film assez
surréaliste et indépendant qui est
actuellement en post production est en
quête de financements et les anciens
projets bon je vous parlais ce soir avec
mon collègue s'appelle fond de sa peine
c'est un projet qui est cherche à venir
les problèmes de la pollution les
descentes plat et l'exclusion sociale on
peut dans l'est moselle d'emmaüs si vous
connaissez mais en version plus tôt
biotechnologiques et en parlant de jcs
je vous présente mon associé et grand
ami julien janin
merci mariana bonsoir à tous tiens à
dire c'est pas vraiment moi sur la photo
à aujourd'hui on trouve vraiment
n'importe quoi sur internet
je viens du sud de la france à toulouse
c'est beaucoup moins original que le
mexique mais j'ai quand même un parcours
assez exotique puisque j'ai commencé
dans la métallurgie
jusqu aux énergies renouvelables en
passant par la technique dans le son
comme intermittent et les travaux sur
cordes et même l'apiculture alors dire
qu au monde de personnes si différente
arrive à faire un projet en commun
enfin j'en sais rien en fait ça mystère
non sérieusement à ce qu'ils nous sommes
motivés c'est on avait une envie en
commun celle de changer notre façon de
consommer oui c'est ça qui nous a
motivés et aujourd'hui nous venons vous
parler d'un sujet qui nous concerne tous
parce que chacun de nous peut être
acteur du changement
moi vous parlez d une problématique très
grave
actuellement une position 300 millions
de tonnes des déchets plastiques par an
soit les poids de toute l'humanité vers
la planète ensemble donc seulement les
5% et recyclés et 10 % vont tomber dans
la mer chaque année
des poissons de plus petits jusqu'aux
plus grandes un jardin en particules qui
sont disséminés partout dans lé social
et qu'elles vont finir bien entendu la
moe société et d'un bon organisme pour
2050 il y aura plus de plastique dans la
mer que des poissons encore chaque année
un million de morceaux et 5000 mamie
ferment pour trouver la mort à cause de
la gestion plastique et on parle déjà
vingt septième continent
rien qu'avec déchets plastiques et c'est
pas une île comme on pourrait s'imaginer
c'est plutôt une soupe des petits
morceaux qui sont partout principalement
dans cinq endroits et qui peut faire
prendre 30 mètres de profondeur
est ce que c'est ça le monde idéal pour
vous est ce que c'est ça notre avenir
l'avenir de nos enfants
je crois que pour nous le monde idéal ce
serait plutôt celui où les hommes
marchent sans laisser d'empreintes
négative derrière eux un monde où chacun
pourrait gagner sa vie dignement et en
respectant la nature qui l'entourent
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui nous avons
il me imaginer une solution
environnementale sociale et solidaire
c'est une aussi laboratoire on économie
circulaire comme vous pouvez voir dans
les petites et ce quel que peu
tremblante et n'importe où dans le monde
nous recyclons de ressources des déchets
agricoles principalement pour développer
des produits innovantes tout en créant
des emplois pour les personnes exclues
du marché du travail au texte merci
désolé je déballe notre prototype
ok ce que ses membres
est ce que cette scène vous semble
connue je parle pas de l'interruption
j'ai parlé des valeurs nous cherchons
aujourd'hui mais on ne veut pas tout ce
qui vient avec
souvent nous n'avons pas le choix
ces petits trucs qui vient avec tout bon
ça ça doit se finir aujourd'hui de plus
en plus on devient des consommateurs
responsables les industriels à notre
tour nous devons suivre cette évolution
de marché pour proposer des produits
alternatifs plus respectueux de
l'environnement dans tout ça
tout ça va partir mais comment et bien
voici la solution alors demandé ce que
c'est peut-être ici on voit pas bien
mais ceux-ci mesdames et messieurs c'est
un champignon
alors ne vous y trompez pas ce petit
bonhomme veut révolutionner notre
consommation
avec ça on peut remplacer presque toutes
les matières plastiques
non vraiment beaucoup de domaines c'est
vraiment énorme tout ce qu'on peut faire
à base de champignons déjà ses
emballages ça se termine et on peut
venir des panneaux isolants pour la
construction même des vêtements du faux
cuir des chaussures du mobilier des
accessoires ce projet il ya encore plus
de choses me perds tu pourquoi pas des
voitures ou des pièces mêlant la liste
est très longue d autant qu ils seront
compris merci
ouais c'est vrai qu'avec ces petites
minutes organismes on peut presque te
faire bon cela c'est difficile à
expliquer c'est un vrai champion
en formant des champignons mais c'est
pas les champignons que vous connaissez
tous évidemment je n'allais pas monter
dans l'avion avec un bref champignons
déjà avec la réputation de mexicains il
s'est laissé dire que je transporte des
champignons on peut le supposer
en parlant de mauvaise réputation bon il
faut dire que le pauvre ami et
champignons sont des êtres assez
incompris comme moi mise à part dans la
majorité des cas on a tendance à les
associer des moisissures plutôt
nuisibles qui s'attaquent aux cultures
de plantes dans la salle de bains mais
il ya aussi les pâtes les champignons
pathogènes qui s'attaquent à notre santé
comme la mycose des pieds ou pas
bref ce que je vous disais c'est que
quand même malgré tout et bien on peut
dire qu'il est quand même plus de
gentils champignons que de méchants un
peu comme avec le mexicain en effet
chaque année on découvre de plus en plus
des nouvelles champignons et de
nouvelles applications dans d'autres
elle et pharmaceutiques pour soigner des
maladies immunitaires et qu'un cerf les
candidats tu as tu d'autres maladies
savamment merveille on négocie et
champignons qu'elles peuvent soigner
laser enlever les métaux lourds les
lithium
tu as tu des choses qui sont la terre
comme jacques malaterre aux sirènes
nourrir des terres pauvres
les reçus au nez il ya des gentils
champignons ainsi que peuvent tuer des
méchants champignons dont les fonds
jedid il ya les surprenants micro siens
et fonctionne comme une espèce d
internet souterrain qui permet de
communiquer des arbres des différentes
espèces entre eux et à distribuer des
nutriments et les changes les ce2 donc
on n'a pas vraiment besoin ni de
pesticides liste des sceaux j'aime la
nature est simplement merveilleuse donc
on a déjà parlé de la virtuosité des
champignons et aussi de la problématique
avec la pollution des plastiques
voyons maintenant un petit peu le point
font le point avec les initiatives qui
existent et celle qui reste encore à
développer
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on commence à
réduire la consommation dans certains
certaines matières plastiques un peu nos
cibles certains proposent des plastiques
oxo dégradables donc son combat qu'est
ce que c'est alors ça reste quand même
des plastiques d'origine du pétrole
alors la nouveauté c'est qu'il se tait
fragmentant milliers de petits morceaux
qui se dispersent dans l'atmosphère et
ninita blement dans la nature donc c'est
quand même un paradoxe d'un côté on nous
dit qu'il faut arrêter de polluer notre
côté en a qui commencent à fabriquer des
mêmes polluants en rajoutant une petite
poudre magique pour les faire
disparaître de notre vue mais sont
toujours là plus petit plus nombreux
idem pour les plastiques des ressources
et donc la législation discutée
il faut qu'elles soient tendres et 30%
des matières compostables
donc normalement des millions des pommes
de terre mais et les incendies pour cent
restants c'est encore issues de pétrole
donc en conclusion les vieux plastiques
ne sont pas vraiment une option durable
en france
la nouvelle législation pour la
transition énergétique dit julien
interdit des bleus sont plus certains
matières polluantes comme on l'a vu les
maintenaient sachets plastiques
cette année ces sachets plastiques homme
qu'on est tous deux supermarchés
c'est une bonne initiative c'est un bon
début mais ça ne reste que la toute
petite pointe de l'iceberg
la vraie problématique de plastique
cette longue bande annonce production
d'emballages industriels pour les
transports donc c'est une urgence que
les gouvernements soutiennent des
solutions innovantes simples sont
compostables pour pour remplacer ces
matières plastiques en 2000 ventes
lorsque les gouvernés stephen dépoli
polypropylène soit interdite alentours
sont nous laisse en australie on met sur
de la remplacer mais grâce aux
innovations et aux pionniers aujourd'hui
on a des solutions
ici c'est ce cultivateur d'algues en
bretagne qui fabrique les matières
plastiques complètement compostables ça
existe déjà ou encore cette femme
espagnole qui s'inspire de l'artisanat
philippins et qui recycle les fibres de
feuilles d'ananas pour fabriquer des
accessoires du cuir etc ou encore
qui nous vient de file de l'indonésie
cette société fabrique des panneaux de
construction isolants à base de mycélium
de champignons donc nous avons même déjà
des solutions très encourageante et
beaucoup de résultats maintenant ça fait
que au niveau en question de volume bien
c'est quand même un challenge d'arriver
à lancer une production et de répondre à
des besoins industriels
en effet nous avons commencé avec les
moyens de bord quand vous pourrez voir
les stations fongiques
on se désiste un lien dans mes 45 mètres
carrés les sports pas des sports
d'exercice les espoirs des champignons
dans mon petit mini frigo donc c'est pas
très bon pour la santé
quoi dire des salons la salle des vins
les prototypes ans dans la compassion
partout donc c'est vraiment laid cucchi
t il comme on dit en espagnol ça veut
dire la porcherie
c'est vraiment un état d'urgence qui on
trouve un lieu pour démarrer notre
activité plus en grande dans ce grand
niveau pour prendre de l'ampleur bon je
fait appel aux agriculteurs aux
producteurs de café evra série qui
veulent leur et valoriser leurs déchets
de nous approcher si comme toute autre
personne qui souhaite c'est adhérer à
notre cause des dix signataires de ce
train les mycologues même les
collectivités les labos de recherche ou
même descendu ce trail nous cherchons un
lieu de travail on peut travailler
ensemble soit un très bon laboratoire
merci n'a rien d'un patient l'a compris
il ya besoin de beaucoup de monde
il reste encore beaucoup à faire mais il
n'ya pas que les institutions qui
peuvent céder parce que nous tous nous
avons le pouvoir d'être acteurs de ce
changement
en devenant des consom'acteurs en
adoptant des gestes écologiques en des
pratiques de consommation consciente et
aussi en favorisant les circuits
éthiques malheureusement bien
aujourd'hui
notre modèle économique actuel et bien
repose sur quatre piliers est bien
ancrée voici d'abord un extraire
produire consommer et jetés en fait
c'est vraiment ce modèle qu'il faudrait
jeter
il est grand temps d'entrer dans l'ère
de l'économie circulaire
or en respectant quelques règles simples
comme celle des 3 r c'est facile
recycler tout ce qui est possible
réutiliser les matériaux usagés et enfin
réduire la quantité de nos déchets dans
cette année de jouer les jeux il devrait
annoncer ce prix à tous ces sales terre
native innovante qui se présente à nous
pour que nos efforts des changements ont
un réel impact
notre environnement
donc je voudrais m'en donne est ce que
vous voulez construire un nouvel avenir
avec nous car nous ne voulons le
façonner pour vous c'est difficile mais
c'est possible
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup